[Music]
on this tuesday night extended relief
for canadians
in a cash crunch you will keep getting
that two thousand dollars a month how
much longer the canada emergency
response benefit will last
and the cost to keep it going ontario's
biggest operators of private
long-term care homes under scrutiny we
think it could have been preventable the
spread of covid
the infection rates in these facilities
promising results from a cheap
common medication this is really really
remarkable
a potential life-saving treatment for
the sickest covid19 patients
and volatile relationship tensions flare
a game between the koreas
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some good news for
millions of canadians still out of work
because of covid19
the federal government has extended the
canada emergency response benefit or
serb for another two months the benefit
provides two thousand dollars per month
to canadians who lost work or cannot
work
due to the pandemic it was initially
available for a maximum of sixteen weeks
paying a total of eight thousand dollars
today's changes mean canadians who need
it can now access
24 weeks of support amounting to twelve
thousand dollars
the prime minister warned today it will
be a long journey ahead with parts of
the economy still
shut down by the pandemic eric sorenson
has more on what the government is doing
to help canadians avoid
financial crisis
clooney is one of thousands of
restaurants in toronto that closed in
march
plunging workers instantly into
unemployment for dylan mawson a server
at clooney
the canada emergency response benefit
has been an absolute lifeline
without it i have no idea what i would
have done i would be
like you know as an adult i would have
been calling my eating my savings and
calling my parents i'm not really sure
for those who started in march that
lifeline would have run out in early
july
now ottawa has added eight weeks for the
first sixteen weeks those eligible
qualified for eight thousand dollars
an additional four thousand over the
summer will bring that to twelve
thousand dollars
to help early qualifiers up to september
critics worry that people will turn down
jobs rather than turn down serb
the prime minister insists the program
is essential the reality is that there
are three million people
out of work who are looking for work and
even as our economy is reopening
there are many many more people out of
work willing to work
than there are jobs available the
overall costs of serb are staggering
with 8 million applicants the benefit
could be as high as 17 billion dollars a
month
the cost so far 43.5 billion dollars
and it will keep rising the opposition
wants more accountability
will he table an economic update before
the house rises
no time frame for an economic update yet
mr speaker throughout this unprecedented
pandemic we
have been open and transparent about all
the measures we put forward the program
will add to canada's debt
but that's necessary says this economist
the canadian government can carry that
debt
the financing costs are lower right now
and i think it did what it was
supposed to do which is like throw a
lifeline to
those individuals that need it the
economy is slowly coming out of its deep
freeze more than a million canadians who
were getting served no longer needed
but in toronto where many restaurants
remain shuttered the emergency benefit
will keep
dillon and thousands like him afloat
i've got
exactly enough money every month to like
pay my bills
cover my debt eat and great
so you're relieved really really yeah
eric sorensen global news toronto
the closure of the canada u.s border is
also being extended the border will
remain shut to non-essential travel
until at least july 21st part of a deal
already extended twice
the border has been closed since march
21st only essential workers trade
shipments and those reuniting with
immediate family members are allowed to
cross
the u.s has more deaths and more
confirmed cases of kobit 19
than any country in the world
temporary foreign workers are among the
people deemed essential in canada during
the pandemic and tonight there's
uncertainty around workers from mexico
the mexican government may be stopping
thousands of them from coming to canada
after two temporary foreign workers died
in canada from covet 19.
as abigail beeman reports the lack of
clarity is stressful
for both those workers and the farmers
gearing up for the busy strawberry
season miller's bay farm would usually
have half a dozen temporary foreign
workers on hand
this year with the delays and
complications we actually only have one
guy
in the field right now and we're looking
forward to two more coming out of
quarantine
shannon miller says they've tried to
fill the gap with local help
but it's not easy their mexican workers
are professionals who have been on the
farm for years
more like family members and friends
news the mexican government may block
more workers from coming to canada
just adds to the stress and uncertainty
i don't want to sound the alarm bells
but you're not going to have the
availability of local food
and then the other thing to think of is
that you know if there's any kind of
shortage in the other countries where we
import from
you can be sure they'll be keeping for
themselves first and sending us
only what's left over the mexican
embassy here in ottawa tells global news
there is a ban
on more workers coming to canada but
farms a non-profit group that helps
bring workers to farms in ontario and
the atlantic provinces
tells us that's not true the mexican
government told them
tuesday morning the ban only applies to
farms where there is an
outbreak otherwise it's quote business
as usual
but the mexican embassy has since
refused to clarify which is correct
by deadline workers are telling us we're
signing a death warrant by
going into canada because the canadian
government has failed to provide
protections
for us to be able to refuse unsafe work
sonia avilas with the migrant workers
alliance for change says workers are
afraid of getting sick
but they still want to come to canada
the work helps them feed their families
various challenges around labor
standards that require
looking at we can even look at things
like pathways towards citizenship that
could
give people more rights but no specific
promises
for a problem that gets worse as the
season progresses
abigail beeman global news ottawa
we know residents in long-term care
homes have been worst hit by covid 19 in
canada
almost one-third of ontario nursing home
residents who have died from it were
living
at facilities owned by just two
corporate chains that's one of the
findings of a global news analysis of
government statistics
which use self-reported data from
long-term care homes
some unions and health care researchers
say the numbers prove
private care homes are more vulnerable
to the novel coronavirus
as ross lord reports others say there
are other factors
that can't be ignored
gestures of healing for families that
lost loved ones in a nightmarish
outbreak
as of june 12th 70 residents had died
from covert 19 at orchard villa in
pickering ontario
victims include 95-year-old george
morrison his daughter is suing the care
home's private owner
we think it could have been preventable
the spread of cobid
with the highest percentage of
for-profit care homes in canada about
two-thirds
some of ontario's private homes have
been especially hard hit by the novel
coronavirus
the two largest owners are sienna senior
living and rivera incorporated
in siena homes 295 residents have died
from covet 19.
rivera homes have seen 230 deaths
six siena homes experienced 20 or more
deaths
compared with four revere homes and four
homes owned by another for profit owner
rika two sienna homes had more than 50
desks
as well as two rivera homes some
researchers blame
staffing they say in general for-profits
rely on temporary workers
who move between homes to earn their
living more heavily than their
non-profit counterparts
who hire more full-time permanent staff
continuity of care makes a really big
difference
to the outcomes so you have better care
outcomes associated with more continuity
it's it's really straightforward but the
industry is pushing back
the ontario long-term care association
says preliminary data
shows a higher percentage of privately
owned homes have no covet 19 deaths
a statement from siena says the vast
majority of our 70 residences across the
country
have experienced few if any cases of
covet 19.
rivera says there are many factors that
play a part in why covet 19 spreads
but that data has not shown ownership is
one of them
others say there's another key factor
design
here at northwood in halifax the virus
has killed 53 people
and critics note the majority of
long-term care residents here live two
or three to a room
which could make it easier for the virus
to spread
northwood is a not-for-profit home do
we need to have all our nursing homes
with a single occupancy and a washroom
for every resident
of their own that is the question that
is really before us here in the province
the question for everyone with a family
member in long-term care are they safe
from the expected second wave of
covet-19
ross lord global news halifax
we have a deeper look at long-term care
home ownership and outbreaks of covid19
that's on our website globalnews.ca
globalnational in the u.s president
trump has signed an executive order
aimed at making law enforcement more
accountable
after weeks of protests and intense
pressure to tackle racism and police
brutality the president is creating
incentives for police forces to improve
their practices
at the same time though he's not toning
down his law and order messaging
jackson proskow reports
[Music]
acknowledging the movement sweeping
across america
president donald trump backed growing
calls for police reform
with his own executive order full of
modest proposals
i will say we've dealt with all of the
various departments
and everybody said it's time
we have to do it trump is calling for
the creation of a national database to
track officers who use excessive force
restricting the use of choke holds
unless an officer's life is in danger
and adding better training to respond to
issues of mental health and addiction
proposals that come nowhere close to
what protesters have demanded
as calls to defund police grow louder
nationwide
americans want law and order they demand
law and order
they may not say it they may not be
talking about it but that's what they
want
in fact trump dismantled many of the
police reforms initiated by the obama
administration
today he's up against a rare moment of
unity in washington
democrats and republicans seem close to
finding common ground
and could vote on police reform
legislation within the next few weeks
now is a moment to reach for real
lasting
strong comprehensive change we cannot
merely make some changes around the
margins
in cities across america where peaceful
protests continue
some local officials have adopted even
stronger measures
nashville and seattle are the latest
cities to ban the use of chokeholds
in atlanta a city still reeling from the
police shooting of richard brooks
the mayor wants to rewrite the book on
officer conduct
we have to objectively look at
de-escalation
that's not very clear in our policies in
a moment when it seems like change
is truly possible there's growing
pressure to make it happen
jackson proskow global news washington
here in canada the military has decided
to put its cyclone helicopter fleet back
into service after the fatal crash in
april off the coast of greece
the military says it's still
investigating the exact cause of that
crash
mechanical failure has been ruled out
based on the flight data recorder it
says during a complex maneuver to land
on the frigate
the flight director's inputs conflicted
with the aircraft's
autopilot settings and that caused the
helicopter to respond in a way
the crew was not expecting the
helicopter slammed into the sea
the military says it's taken steps to
prevent future issues with the software
including
updating its training manual it plans to
have its cyclone fleet
back in service in the coming days i
assure you
this decision was not taken lightly i
have full confidence
in our personnel at 12 wing share water
and in their
ability to resume flying activities in a
safe manner
all six canadian service members on
board were killed in that crash on april
29th
it was the deadliest day for the
canadian armed forces in more than a
decade
a canadian fitness icon on the record
about racism
coming up how hal johnson turned
discrimination into
inspiration for body break
the prime minister is working hard to
win at canada a seat on the u.n security
council and
the campaigning is intense justin
trudeau spent a lot of time
on the phone today with leaders in india
spain ethiopia and elsewhere
our chief political correspondent david
aiken joins me david what is the focus
of his pitch
well the pitch is as much you'd expect
donna canada is a strong team player
well connected as a member of the g7 the
g20 the commonwealth
the francophone e but since the coven 19
pandemic hit
there has been a new twist to canada's
pitch
canada is now selling itself as a
wealthy country
with the resources expertise and
willingness to help smaller countries
with their health and economic
challenges
as we look at the kind of world we're
going to come out to come out of
post covet we need a country like canada
that is
big enough to make a difference but
small enough to know we can't do it
alone and we will continue to work
together
but canada has some challenges of its
own to overcome first of all
its rivals norway and ireland have been
campaigning for a decade
canada just started when trudeau got
elected in 2015
and every time a liberal politician here
be it trudeau or anyone else
tried to take a dig at the previous
harper government by saying
canada is back well norway would pipe up
and say
norway never left so canada's
inconstancy donna has been something
that its rivals have really been playing
up
david how likely does it appear then
that canada will get the votes it needs
to win a seat
well put it this way members of the
canadian delegation at the u.n in new
york tell me
they are quote cautiously optimistic now
that said
this is a secret ballot and anything can
happen consider this
in 2010 canada had written
assurances from 135 countries that they
would all vote for
canada in writing and on that first
ballot only 114
kept their word and this was what
happens all the time with these votes
that some countries we don't know which
ones say one thing
and then do another so we will see and
of course we lost that 2010 vote
now voting in new york begins at 9 00
a.m
wednesday insiders tell me norway
is likely leading the pack with canada
nipping at ireland's heels
the u.n says they expect first ballot
results
by about 4 pm eastern donna all right
david aiken in ottawa
thanks the u.n security council was
created after the second world war and
its primary responsibility is
maintaining world peace
it is the un's most powerful body and
membership is coveted
here's how it works there are 15 seats
on the council
five belong to permanent members china
france
russia the uk and the u.s the 10
remaining non-permanent seats
have two-year terms and they're
distributed on a regional basis
five seats are reserved for african and
asian nations
there are two seats for latin america
one for eastern europe
and two for western europe and other
countries including canada
this year canada is competing with
norway and ireland for the two open
spots
to win a country must receive two-thirds
of all votes cast for the seat
that means canada must get at least 128
votes from the 193
u.n members casting ballots multiple
rounds of voting may be needed
to reach that threshold
the steroid that's showing promise in
the pandemic
up next who it helps
there is still no vaccine and no
treatment for covid19 but today the uk
government did approve the use of a drug
to treat people who are
severely ill with covid19 it's an
existing steroid that is cheap and
widely available
it is not a cure and it doesn't work on
every patient but as crystal commansing
explains it's offering some hope where
until now
there's been none this steroid used to
treat inflammation
could soon be used around the world to
try and save
incredibly sick covid19 patients
it really is showing quite a significant
effect and it's really important because
the drug itself
is very widely available it's on almost
every pharmacy shelf in every hospital
one of the big challenges with covid19
is trying to stop the body's immune
system from going into overdrive and
attacking itself
a so-called cytokine storm in a trial
led by oxford university
2 000 patients requiring respiratory
support and given
dexamethasone or compared to more than
four thousand
treated without it it's not a drug that
you would use
in the community or in outpatients or in
patients on the wall who didn't have
breathing difficulties
according to the findings dexamethasone
helped prevent the death of
one in every eight covid19 patients on
ventilators
for patients being treated with oxygen
the drug prevented one death in every 25
patients treated
i'm quite honestly elated i thought that
our colleagues in united kingdom did a
fantastic job
uh the top line results were certainly
very impressive dr matthew chang
anticipates the drug will now be used
in canada this is the first medicine
that's been shown to reduce death
in any group with covid and that's
the start of something so it shows this
is possible to do
and as other drugs get looked at the
hope is that they'll add on top of that
hope is exactly what's needed more than
8 million people have been infected
worldwide with more than 400 thousand
deaths so far
crystal gomansen global news london
north korea has sent an explosive
message to its southern counterpart
and the world the north blew up a
building known as the joint liaison
office where officials from north and
south korea had recently worked side by
side
the building has reportedly been vacant
since january because of the pandemic
it opened in 2018 and allowed the first
full-time person-to-person contact
between the koreas
which have technically been at war for
decades relations have deteriorated
over the past year next
the back story on body break and it has
nothing to do
with fitness
a calls for racial justice in the united
states and here in canada have sparked
important conversations about racism
hal johnson and his wife joanne are well
known from participation's body break
he has encouraged canadians to get up
and get fit for more than 30 years
now he's telling the story of how his tv
career began
you think that body break was started
because of fitness well it wasn't
it was started to combat racism
body break became an institution on
canadian television but johnson
explained the idea for the exercise
segment came up
after he got hired for a job at tsn in
april of 1988.
hours later someone higher up in the
company said
no to putting him on air because they
already had
a black sports caster after a second
racist
incident months later johnson says he
sat down to figure out a way
to bring people together and i thought
how can i
how can i change things how can i make
that we can all live work and play
together and there won't be
this attitude that that white and black
and
asian and persons with disabilities and
male female we all can't be together
so i came up with this idea and the idea
is body break
today tsn apologized for what it calls a
shameful part of its past
the network thanked johnson for sharing
his story as a reminder of the impact of
racism in canadian media that continues
today in its statement the network said
we've recognized that even 30 years
later there is still much work to do to
improve our commitment
to on-air and editorial diversity
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen
we leave you tonight with a centenarian
who is retiring
his name is diego and he's a giant
galapagos tortoise who also happens to
have a giant
libido thanks to a breeding program
diego has about 800
offspring and is credited with almost
single-handedly saving his
once-threatened species
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye
you